welcome to this video where this is a
new Blitz game on the
IC and for for some reason the board
sounds are off why is that this is
irritating
me the general sounds are
on let me do one thing
here unmute the whole thing I'm really
used to this thought thought this this
kind of kind of sounds
okay this is
H this guy was playing B3 all the time
and uh he's done so
here
okay I will ultimately play D5 but after
some some
prep or not is it not advisable to do
yeah maybe still do it why not it cannot
be that great for white
I mean certainly okay for him but it
should be should be an okay position huh
should I prevent maybe let's let's
prevent any before
ideas it's difficult
to get something active going here he is
Knight C4 all the
time attacking my five Pawn I'm just
going
to play it very in a very simple fashion
if
possible let's
see yeah D4 yeah D4 might might
happen yeah one advantage of the white
setup is that he can dash out all those
moves uh quite quickly it's all very
simple to
play Knight to C5 maybe H and
D4 yeah let's counter attack
B3 so D4 is not happening maybe Knight
C4 is
coming okay I'm going
to just put stuff in the
middle okay yeah I didn't really
appreciate it that much this move okay
so I have to take there is no no big
Choice
yeah giving up the bishop here is
nothing that I liked very
much yeah it's I don't really have a
great plan in this
position it's rather comfortable for
white the whole
thing
not sure about the queen trade he can
also just
Retreat or put it there okay but if I go
Rook D5 where is the queen going
actually where is it
going isn't this a
problem
H yeah I think it is a problem
white resigns that was a really sudden
end to this game here I think I'm just
worse I mean I think he has unpleasant
Choice he can Retreat which is probably
probably best or can exchange Queens I
mean this also is is some Advantage for
white he has two Bishops longterm a nice
thing to have and he has this pressure
on the
seile um yeah but it's not easy I think
it's it's better to keep the Queens on
really just do that and then come with
Knight C4 later and or Knight E4 again
yeah you can try to get the Knight to C5
yet
again the second the second
Knight yeah that's good for
white yeah this whole setup um is
probably not not that precise here what
I what I
played I mean definitely play able it's
not totally bad
but not sure how to set up the pieces
correctly here I think
maybe maybe I should go D5 even earlier
here like like
here huh I don't know I'm not a huge
expert here on on this line but
um it um it really seemed nice for white
like here it is a fairly standard um
kind of Hedgehog setup that white has
but what I'm lacking here is a clear um
clear attacking Target it's not not so
clear what black is doing
here trying to centralize but here also
D4 was
interesting not so clear what I'm doing
now yeah that wasn't a great great setup
I probably should improve on that okay I
hope you like the game being short but
but still thanks for watching watching